it is big and barely governor ball and
Ebola has taken hold in the Democratic
Republic of Congo the aid agencies and
local officials are waging war on the
virus but they're losing the fight they
cannot contain the disease so
organizations like the World Food
Program have ramped up their response
and we joined them in an armed convoy as
they ventured into territory held by
local militia situation here is very
volatile and can change from one hour to
to another well we need to always
reassess the situation it's a hot spot
and the WFP hasn't been here before but
the aid agencies have to expand their
operations and win support of those on
the ground we're gonna meet the local
chief were where visitors here and we
need his his permission to be here
health workers are frequently attacked
by Congolese who don't believe in bowler
exists but the local chief assured us
we'd be able to travel safely 30
kilometers up the road we reached a
distribution center where hundreds were
queuing up for food and there was
something special about this group each
one has been in direct contact with a
victim of Ebola they're all considered
high-risk Blaise muhabba pleads with
villagers to keep their distance for
Ebola is spread by spit and sweat can
you stop it can you stop the spread of
this virus is it possible say possibly a
publicist Aviles on circumvent a
separatist prison party they be in the
park or movie the Dead is at the ODE
pastillage of Via della for a May up to
the militiamen the WFP
is using food as its principal weapon
with a sack of rice and beans the
villagers of Aloha are less likely to
travel they're less likely to spread the
virus you feel scared sometimes in
melodic una vaca Jew I jog walk into a
gang geography to us our immunization
more than sixty have died from Ebola in
this village three suspect cases were
detained in this Shack on the morning of
our visit they were taken to a treatment
facility where doctors work in
specialist rooms called cubes but there
is no cure for this infection and the
majority here will die well we're
heading over to the cubes now with the
doctors and you know they've got no more
beds left in this place the facility is
absolutely full and the suspect cases
well they don't bring them here anymore
they're all assessed on the other side
of the road I really can't think of a
more challenging or a more testing place
to work more than 16 hundred and fifty
people have lost their lives to Ebola
since the virus took hold but there is
reason to hope this baby nicknamed
Jeremy was born in a cube and doctors
think the child and his mother may
survive but they'll need extraordinary
support like the country they live in if
they're going to recover from Ebola John
Sparkes Sky News in Benny